okay I thought this video was actually
going to have a decent length but it's
just 9 minutes because I thought that
this video was like two and a half hours
long which it was and then I checked it
out and it was actually like half an
hour of just completely me doing nothing
so I think I actually kept the recording
when I was going to have dinner it was
something like that
in any case it suddenly turned out to be
a lot shorter than I expected so I'm
sorry about that that being said though
I still find many discussions on many of
the videos asking if I wanna make these
videos longer how it even works
I might actually make a separate video
on that just explained the entire let's
play thing but usually ten minutes of
let's play is two hours of rollercoaster
can three and two hours of what
microsecond three is a perfect timescale
to be streaming or playing on myself and
trying to get longer sessions is a bit
tough and otherwise recording in shorter
sections and then time lapsing those
shorter sections is not very handy and
does it really work for me so that's why
I aim to go for about ten minutes per
let's play but then even let's plays
that are under nine minutes long it's
actually not my aim so that's kind of
that another thing is that in this
episode I'm doing a train station which
is pretty much the thing that's going
down I actually did have a lot of very
specific episodes lately which is
awesome because I like that but that
doesn't mean that in the future I'm
actually gonna have to do some more
smaller details and stuff again because
after the clock tower was finished I
didn't do anything on the facades that
are going to be surrounding it
or the path works or anything else then
the clock tower itself and the same is
going to go for this station also a did
feature quite a lot of just me trying to
figure out what I wanted to do with the
station the idea that I had in mind
really the toughest thing that I had for
this station was to translate the image
that I had in my mind into a building in
Veliko ii 3 which was due to not
entirely knowing how i should do it i
know entirely knowing what custom
scenery I should use for it so there's
quite a bit of removing things and kind
of changing things a tiny bits I do
think that in the end it did come out
all right
so um the basic idea over here was
basically to get a
very small English sort of small station
that you would have on a train station
which is quite a rare thing on its own
there were a couple of other ideas that
I had considered such as a factory
industrial sort of setting for the
station or to get a larger building in
but I wanted to do a station a real
train station for a cohesive station
because even though it seems like
something that really does not happen
and it's very unorthodox I felt like it
was something that I didn't have in the
English area yet and it was something
that I think it would be enough of a
recognisable English theme and something
that I could pull off well that I wanted
to get in there so yeah that's basically
it small English train station house and
then have that sort of I don't know what
it's called entirely but usually you
know when you have those train stations
and it's just one small house you have
that very small roof with Victorian
pillars and fences and decorations that
covers the well train track and stuff so
I wanted to get that in here the only
real downside to this is that the exits
part of the track is outdoors so not the
greatest thing when it's raining but at
least the the entrance part is within a
building because the umpire I'm
currently building with this building
over here is well have the station gates
and which is where the queue should come
out and then on the other side which is
just gonna stay open and not really have
anything else I'm going to have the
exits of the station and that's
basically how it works I did find it
quite funny though at the time that's I
was trying to get that real English look
so I searched through sense that I
thought had the English look going for
them which many of them did to be quite
honest really good textures and custom
CV pieces that I could work with but
they didn't really work together too
well the country insult was a set which
I do like but it didn't really work for
whatever reason it actually was I think
there were certain problems with that
not sticking out enough not having the
right roofs and eventually the set that
I ended up using for the entire building
so this means the walls the roofs and
the dormers is ralphie's American beaver
in homes so um yeah it's a it's a it's
an English trade station but
using American suburb house custom
scenery sets so I probably should not
have certain that because that might
just destroy the magic but um that's
that's how it is I just found that quite
funny in hindsight how I was actually
searching through all kinds of stuff for
about 30 to 40 minutes trying to get the
things that I really wanted right and in
the end ended up going with the thing
that I lost expected to go for was quite
funny which also results in the end in a
train station that is actually really
quite simple but that I still spent
quite some time on trying to perfect and
things but yeah this is basically what I
meant with that sword of overhanging
roof with Victorian posts and all that
stuff and the reason why I wanted to do
this as well is that I would have liked
to get the very typical train station
arches in in the way that I had them for
the train station in the touch area but
I already had that in the train station
for the Dutch area so if it were not
afford that fact I probably would have
tried them over here as well but I
didn't want to have a similar or pretty
much the exact same train station very
close to two different things so yeah I
just decided to try this instead I do
think it kind of works I do see it kind
of happening over here the only thing
that I am still not too sure about is
whether it could actually be realistic
enough for a bnm coaster station because
it really is a train station after all
and it's not entirely a well-coached ER
station I think it's doing the job well
enough plus the fact that it does
actually provide a pretty nice view I
think that's something that I also
really wanted to keep in mind and that
is also the reason why it might seem a
bit of a weird location next to the
lifts hill over there I wanted to make
sure that it would look good if you were
going to approach it from the rest of
the past
and since you approach this area from
the other side of the Dutch train
station kind of from the general
direction of the English area I wanted
this building to look good from that
direction I actually did not care too
much about the other directions which
also made it
in a way that's you know it doesn't look
too good from other directions but on
the other side there is the
rollercoaster so you wouldn't really see
it too much from that side and that's
something that I always try to keep in
mind that a building should look good
from one particular or two particular
perspectives and this is especially true
in theme parks you really don't even
have to care that much about the
particular perspectives make sure that
you build a building in a way that it
looks in a way that you want it from one
angle and just forget about the rest you
can do that later on which is kind of
what happened with this building you can
see it kind of recognized it because I
only finished the back side of the
building at the end really after the
front was finished and I was happy about
that I went over to the back side just
to kind of finish that and make it
realistic but it's really not that
important for the overall design of this
thing so that's why I kind of was a bit
sloppy also on the back I really don't
care too much about the back it sounds
really bad to say that but it's really
not too important for me how that how
the back of the building looks since you
know you're just not going to really see
it and yeah that's basically my story of
perspectives and why I give shits about
the Front's of buildings sometimes but I
don't give [ __ ] about the backs of
buildings sometimes that being said this
does not count if you have a building
that can be surrounded by paths or any
sort of viewing point from all angles
make sure that actually looks good from
every angle and don't just sloppily
quickly do the other sides of the
buildings without care but if you have
buildings like these that are a kind of
place towards the edge of a park and you
can't really see them from other
perspectives I like to just be a lazy
douchebag and just not care and button
the back side of the building I think
it's ER I think it's alright
but yeah I think I'm running out of time
almost almost the one last thing that I
was still doing over here was doing the
little and exits path which is really
just to get down from the little
platform that the station is on but it's
written a lot special I'm actually look
at it later on the only only reason why
I did it this awkwardly is because there
are no inclined curved railings so I had
to get stone but in any case that's it
this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode
Oh video soon